how are you doing today we've all been
running around blackout for the past
week and popping those special abilities
like tic tacs without really knowing
what they're doing to our insides so
let's break down how some of these work
in the early mid and late game now these
are just our recommendations and you may
like to play differently so let us know
how you use these abilities in the
comments below also we don't expect you
to remember them all that's why we have
our handy dandy guide up on gamespot
let's talk about perk categories and why
they're useful early game so you've hit
the ground and it's looter die time
people around you are picking up guns
but instead all you're finding are
bandages and special abilities what's a
person to do to cure that lack of weapon
problem focus on these look for looter
reveals nearby loot and stashes loot
equals guns guns equal good engineer
reveals all nearby vehicles and enemy
equipment so you can find that mode of
transportation and GTFO while everyone
else merrily kills each other
brawler increases melee damage and
gained 50 health for each melee attack
landed if you can pull this off you're
probably a lot better than us and you
should tell us how awesome you are in
the comments below we really doubt most
of you will brawl your way to victory
but this ability at least gives you a
fighting chance to mate to the mid game
speaking of the mid game now that you're
on the move towards you are clearly
impending victory with that blue wave of
death at your backside these abilities
will help you stay aware of where your
team is where enemy players are and
increase your chances of getting the
drop on them
Outlander take less damage and move
faster when outside the safe zone this
one's particularly helpful if you get
caught outside of the blue wave squad
link teammates are visible through walls
so you can see what the hell they're up
to
paranoia gives you audio cues for when
you're being targeted by an enemy via
aim down sights or just gives you that
pervasive feeling that's somebody's
watching you the next three mid game
abilities help you be more deadly and
then just more dead awareness ladder
enemy footsteps dead silence silent
movement and less noise when opening
stashes skulker faster crouch and prone
movement and iron lungs which helps you
steady your aim while scoped or
increases your time underwater these
abilities together just make you a lot
more quiet and a lot more deadly to
other players we've also had some debate
the office over saving engineer for mid
to late game so here's the argument it
could potentially show you where
somebody is hiding in a building if they
set up razor wire or mesh mines to cover
their back it can also give you more
specific locations of vehicles that you
can't locate by sound alone
the final circles all right so you've
made it to the final couple rings and
it's do-or-die time any advantage at
this point would be really helpful
fortunately you brought along and saved
these handy abilities consumer health
and consumable items activate 50% faster
so you get your team up faster and die
less while doing so medic health items
and team revives replenish more health
with faster activation kind of
self-explanatory more help for stim shot
mobility movement and weapons switch
faster you can fire and use items while
sprinting and move faster while
reloading fall damage is also negated
reinforced reduces explosive and fire
damage and reduces effectiveness of
razor-wire flashbangs and concussion
grenades because let's be honest
you'll probably blind yourself about
half the time or more using flashbang
and concussion grenades stimulant
increase health cap by a hundred so yeah
all of these things make you faster and
a bit more powerful when you're trying
to get those last couple of kills we
want to know what you're thinking about
in black ops for it are you playing a
number of modes or sticking with black
out as always put your best advice and
little-known secrets in the comments
below if they're awesome
they may even end up in the next video
thanks for watching
you fight and all objective-c late we
stand out the future
you